[Música]
y en directo a Vamos hasta Londres para
hablar con nuestra corresponsal Luisa
Pulido que tiene los detalles de la
posesión del issstrass como nueva
primera ministra de Reino Unido se trata
de la cuarta líder conservadora en seis
años que llega al poder después de la
salida de Boris Johnson tras los
escándalos que sacudieron su mandato
desde el número 10 de Downey Street
residencia oficial de los mandatarios
británicos tros dejó claro Cuáles eran
las prioridades de su gobierno Luisa muy
buenas noches cuéntenos que se destaca
del primer discurso detrás
en una jornada marcada por las lluvias
torrenciales y sin dar mayores detalles
en las puertas de Down Street la primera
ministras entregó las tres prioridades
de su plan de gobierno unas horas
después de convertirse oficialmente en
la nueva primera ministra británica la
56 en la historia del país esto después
de reunirse en una audiencia con la
Reina Isabel II la jefe de estado y se
convierte de esta manera en la primera
ministra número 15 en los 70 años del
reinado de Isabel segunda estas tres
prioridades son para aliviar la economía
para reconstruir la recuperarla Eso
incluye bajar los impuestos que es una
promesa de campaña del disfraz también
aliviar la crisis de los hogares Y los
negocios por el aumento en los precios
de la energía detalles que serán
revelados
simplemente este jueves pero lo que se
sabe es que listras anunciará muy
probablemente un congelamiento los
precios de esta y tercero mejorar el
sistema de salud pública en its y ha
prometido que los médicos tendrán más
citas disponibles listas ha tenido por
supuesto unas primeras horas como
primera ministra Bien ajetreadas también
ha conversado esta noche con el
presidente de Ucrania glodomir Celeste
quien le ha prometido que el Reino Unido
seguirá dando respaldo durante toda la
ocupación rusa seguirá por supuesto
entregando recursos económicos y
políticos y ha dicho que puede contar
con el apoyo británico a largo plazo
Luis hablemos ahora del gabinete del is
Trust Cuáles han sido sus nombramientos
hasta el momento
como primera ministra de manera oficial
distrasa ha empezado a conformar su
gabinete ya la mayoría de los cargos
importantes están nombrados este
gabinete ha sido definido como diverso y
en él se encuentran varios de los
rivales detrás en esta carrera del
partido conservador para convertirse en
líder de la colectividad y Por ende
Primer Ministro son ellos por ejemplo
Penny Morgan que ha sido designada como
líder en la cámara de los comunes ella
era la gran favorita de los diputados
conservadores para hacer premiere para
hacer primera ministra suela braverman
que ha sido designada ministra del
interior que será encargada entre otras
de implementar ese programa bien
polémico de enviar a los inmigrantes
ilegales a Ruanda un país que tiene
bajísimos estándares en la protección de
los Derechos Humanos en los cargos
importantes también ha sido designados
en ministro de finanzas cuasi parte
James cleverly es el nuevo ministro de
exteriores que mi baden no que también
fue competidora detrás ha sido designada
secretaría de estado para comercio
internacional ha sido ratificado Del
ministro de defensa vengo a las que es
bien importante en este mensaje que ha
ratificado hoy listas con la
conversación con el presidente de
Ucrania y es que el Reino Unido seguirá
dando apoyo militar y político a Ucrania
en la guerra contra Rusia y también ha
sido ratificado a los sharma que es el
presidente de la cop 26 eso significa
que el Reino Unido va a seguir
trabajando en sus compromisos para
reducir las emisiones de efecto
invernadero para el 2050 Y también todos
los compromisos medio ambientales